what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today we are going to watch
the trailer
for the last duel starring
adam driver kylo ren matt
jason ben affleck the the movie where he
was legit
alcoholic basketball coach yeah that's
the reference you guys want to hear
anywho ridley scott directed gods and
kings exodus
and some other period peace movies eddie
who i'm excited for this let's see
what's in store
[Music]
there is only one question that matters
do you swear on your life
what you say is true
the father told me my life will be
blessed with good fortune
really scott is back oh yeah
[Laughter]
i'm married
mad damon i was a good wife
the driver you son of a [ __ ]
raise mom
judged and shamed by my country wow
i say before all of you
i spoke the truth
the most unspeakable charge has been
brought against you
chocolatry entered our home
he attacked me the accusation is false
[Music]
are you telling the truth the truth does
not matter
there is only the power of men
this should be settled quietly ain't
innocent
i request a duel to the death if you oh
no
your wife will suffer dire consequences
one of us has lied let us let god decide
you do not believe me i am risking my
life for you
you are risking my life
the penalty for bearing false witness
is that you are to be burned alive
i will not be silent
[Music]
yeah man i'm a little a little taken
aback off not that i didn't expect it's
heavy subject matter so i guess it has
to be intense but yeah
it has like all this grit and and
pump of like yeah like a big night
adventure
except you know very much contained to
this one messed up
yeah man all this movie's missing is
russell crowe that's awesome
bingo i can't help but think that like
you know the only thing to help us flesh
out
this cast that much more how can you
knock it if you're a film lover
uh how can you not get excited at the
idea unless you just happen to not like
all these actors but
you got adam driver in here who is just
one of our best modern actors that we
have today and then you got matt damon i
thought it would be a little bit more
matt damon and ben affleck because i
remember hearing about this plot
like a couple years ago when it was
first announced you know got to be
careful of some key words here that's
not even mentioned in the description
box of this 20th century fox video but
yeah
basically if you guys couldn't pick up
on it um
jody comer who is in free guy yeah yes
and as also rey's mom she is uh
accusing it i thought it was going to be
ben affleck's yeah
i did too and that's i think just the
the everybody sees ben affleck and matt
damon they're like they must be the two
leads entangled and i thought adam
driver would be the third supporter yeah
oh you're the actually the other lead in
this movie which is funny because then
during the trailer i was like okay so
what is ben affleck actually gonna do in
this
i don't know it looks like he's kind of
higher up on the hierarchy of the
kingdom here
like a prince or a king or something
like that some sense of royalty
i'm not sure but yeah she accuses of
sexual assault towards adam driver
and now they're having a duel over it
but i i actually like how there seems to
be a debate about
whether the it's like a really relevant
topic right now
an edgy top edgy subject to approach but
there's a debate
over like are you telling the truth
these accusations being thrown left and
right adam driver obviously saying he
didn't do it
matt damon torn over the conflict of
someone who he cares about
who has now been accused his best friend
right yeah and
having to deal with like i'm putting my
whole reputation on i'm fighting for you
but really it's about your pride you're
not even really thinking about her
feelings
you know there's a whole lot here that
as much of a period piece as it is it's
very relevant towards today
but even if you isolate the political
commentary of today
it just looks like a really good period
drama absolutely you know
it's like you got your a24 period dramas
like the green knight and then you got
here which does remind you of like the
gladiator
kingdom of kingdom of heaven heaven yeah
the orlando bloom
the good versions director's cut so yeah
seeing ridley scott return back to this
not doing that exodus gods and kings
crap but doing something that feels
really gritty
personal with just great performances
all around where the violence looks
like uh uncomfortable and gritty yeah
everything looks like it has the weight
of this horrible circumstance on top of
it and it does
feel like a ridley scott period epic
without feeling like
a robin hood ridley that's period epic i
mean he's kind of swayed but
it just felt like back to the older
heart r versions of ridley scott yeah
like
it'll be really dark and and heavy in a
lot of its
physical circumstance like the duel
looks intense but also all of the
interpersonal stakes look intense and it
is like a
a very timeless and important
from what i understand the vega man i
understand you know legend
in french history and it was the last
you know like legit
sanctioned duel so like it's it seems as
an outsider like a fascinating tale and
you know as much as i go back and forth
on ridley scott these days i'm like this
does look like something
he could pack a punch with that's what i
mean you're adapting like a legendary
tale
based on a true story and on top of that
too something that
is relevant towards today and also just
looks like a really good historical
period piece drama
yeah with awesome acting great
production design yeah ridley scott kind
of returning to form
and with the thing that won him best
pitcher gladiator one best picture right
yeah
i think so yeah i remember that delivery
so yeah i i think
i was pleasantly surprised and jody
comber looks uh awesome too as like the
central
of of this war between me and in the
worst
exactly like it's all her pride and it's
her word and it's her entire life and
reputation and it's all in matt damon's
hand yeah that's what i mean
yeah it's like and i'm curious to see
how the movie because there has been
some controversy around just this movie
being made and it has to be handled the
right way but i'm curious to see how it
portrays her because it seems like she
is in the roughest position as a
character of anybody
it looks like it's gonna have a just a
crazy escalating build and i wonder
what side it'll ultimately take in the
end
yeah i mean that's part of the you know
the whole the reason it's
endured so long is because there's so
much to debate and that yeah i'm curious
to see how they're going because the the
trailer itself doesn't take an
approach of adam driver definitely did
it you know
yes i mean it certainly draws the
suspicion but it also raises the
question
and i don't want to i don't want to
believe adam driver
we just said adam driver could never i
would it's not capable i
would never see the character let me see
adam drive forever
the funny guy from snl that's how i know
him yeah man
the intern from the star wars sketch
yeah matt the intern he would never
oh gosh guys this was surprisingly
awesome um i i liked it a lot more than
i expected to
guys what do you think about this
trailer leave your thoughts down below i
am playing with my hair too much that's
to look weird
look at that not even puffy it's just
like this weird spider crawl
yeah that's your new style dude you
would fit in into
14th century france man just get
yourself some armor
oh you're from france and a period piece
i've come from spain
subscribe to real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
leave your thoughts down below for this
movie that is crossing over
jason bourne kylo ren and batman all in
[Music]
one